Sometimes the ball gets so hot I will set it on the floor beside our bed. Is this okay to do?
Is it still effective next to our bed?
Yes, it is. But remember the farther the bulb is away to
your body, the you are
losing effectiveness.
So if you're too hot, I always
recommend that you just move the ball maybe a foot away from you on your bed.
Even if you're sleeping in a single bed, you should still be able to be lying comfortable with
the ball a foot away from you in bed. If if you're putting it on the floor beside your bed,
you're still getting some benefits. I will say that. We've had some line patients that have
had to put the bulb in the next room and run it and go slowly in the kill program in order to get
to where they're not herxied enough where they can bring it into the room. However, it is
when you're trying to kill cancer patients, you're not worried about herxia, you're concerned
about the heat of the bulb and it's discomfort because you're warm. But you so you need it
is close to you as possible. But that being said, yes, you could put it 12 to 18 inches away from you
and try to be as comfortable as possible. If it's three feet on the floor and it's going
partially through the mattress to get to you, it's definitely going to have some filtration
and you're going to definitely lose some effectiveness.